hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in this
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Stephanie who
asks hi Evan I need your help on how to
actually speak to a customer or client
when I'm first meeting him or her the
thing is I'm a sales rep and I get
confused as to what I'm supposed to say
or how to introduce a service I need
your help
kind regards seventy so separately
there's a lot of toys to sell it depends
on your personality but what I'm going
to do is share with you how I saw one of
my services and hopefully this and
lessons you can learn from that so the
service ID style is called a mastermind
group and this is a membership program
that I use for Toronto entrepreneurs and
we meet once a month to talk about our
businesses and we try to help each other
out to grow our businesses so it's a
little informal advisory group for your
business now people are first find out
about it it's usually via my website so
by the time they're contacting me they
already have some kind of interest in
the product if you don't have that yet
if you have to create an awareness yet
then your first step is to come up with
a benefit statement that can really
capture somebody's attention very
quickly and get them interested in
learning more about your product or
service what happens that if somebody
finds out about it they'll email me and
I'll always set up a face-to-face
meeting and we usually meet over coffee
and I want to meet them face-to-face
because it gets some buy-in for them
it's easy to do an email easy to do a
phone call but with for meeting they're
taking time out of the day and they have
a vested interest in learning a little
bit more and spending some more time on
it so I want to make sure I got that
commitment before I started to spend a
lot of mine comment as well when I first
meet them for coffee I'll ask them a
little bit about their business their
history what their problems are and
based on that I'll be able to tailor the
discussion to be able to help them solve
their problems right if they have a
strong pain point and you're able to
help solve that you're much more likely
to get the sale so what I'll do is I'll
always ask about the challenges they're
facing and for every person I meet it
could be a different child
so it could be having problems with a
business partner or trying to raise
capital or trying to grow their business
and get more sales and marketing
whatever it is is a different challenge
for every person and so I don't make
sure I know what their main points are
before us are talking about what I have
to offer so we'll spend some time
talking about their business that pain
points they're having and then once
you've had any discussion around that
I'll say well let me tell you a little
bit more about our service and you can
see if it's a fit for you or not and
answer any questions hopeful that you
have and usually then you'll say yes
it's great let's learn more and again
I'm getting their body so you want to
make sure that it's not just a sales
presentation that at the end they say
yes or no to but they have an active
role in the entire discussion so it
starts off with them talking about it
and people love talking about themselves
and so that gets them a little bit more
invested too into your potential product
or service and hopefully close in a sale
and then by learning more about them
you're able to tailor your presentation
to be able to fit the particular or
sales problems that they're happening at
their company so I hope that helps
that's a little bit of how I will first
get introduced to a client and start the
sales process if you have extra
questions you know let me know in the
comments below I'd also love if you can
give it a thumbs up and stay tuned for
the next episode
you